so major Canadian screen awards were
handed out last night this was virtually
done and shits Creek leaned up at one
check this out
best comedy series Best Lead Actor for
Dan levy Best Supporting Actress for
Emily Hampshire and Catherine O'Hara won
her fifth straight CSA for Best Lead
Actress ya mazing yeah and Seth Rogen
it's currently binging the show and he
tweeted Catherine O'Hara is
inspirational she proves some people
just keep getting funnier and funnier
and funnier so after finally being
nominated for an Emmy last year and this
year being the show's final season
people are wondering this will finally
be the year that Catherine wins an Emmy
last night she gave a hilarious
acceptance speech from home Wow thank
you kind Canadian Screen Academy members
I hope you and your families are well
and enjoying the great indoors I feel
like one very lucky lady to have worked
on shits Creek was bite
[Applause]
[Music]
with Maya my dear friend Yugi Levy and
his infinitely talented son Daniel
[Music]
wonderful writers and directors members
[Music]
amazing
Nelson Stevie says I love this woman she
deserves all the accolades yeah it's
gonna be interesting to see what happens
at the Emmys because yeah Julian or
Dreyfus isn't around anymore if you roll
a bridge one last year so yeah and yeah
Lily it was last year that Catherine
O'Hara finally got a nomination for
should people been calling for it for
you know four seasons before that but
yeah it's gonna be I think she will when
people are still talking about Rachel
Brosnahan for marvelous basil but she's
already won but it seems like everyone
seems to be talking about Catherine
O'Hara in the last year so I think it
will happen
yeah and I'll tell you and you do see in
some awards shows where you sort of get
the sense that this was an award for the
body of work and not necessarily for the
part that they were nominated for and
I'll tell you this if that happens with
Catherine O'Hara I'm fine with it
I really am and and because if all of
her flirting with Emmys over the years
has sort of come to this point at the
shows and I think that this is the
perfect opportunity to to give her that
Emmy but I also think it's the perfect
time to because if there's an Emmys sort
of after you know self isolation and
Quarantine and everything else people
discovered this show through binging and
people discovered this show through
streaming and a show like shits Creek is
really this sort of comfort and it's the
thing that people are using to get them
through times like these and I think
that somebody like Catherine O'Hara
needs to be recognized for her role in
maintaining sanity with millions of
people who are really losing it right
now yeah MBS says it would be the right
time to win she deserves it unless yes
Catherine O'Hara is the absolute best
and we saw a little clip of it beyond
like her in that finale was just amazing
her at the altar you know being the
official for the wedding was just like
she just nailed it completely like being
emotional being funny at the same time
so it was a great episode to end her
character on it and really this is my
kind of character that she created over
the last a sixth season it's funny in
the interview that she just gave to
Vanity Fair
she said about losing the Emmy last year
she wasn't really upset about losing the
award she was upset that she had a
really good bit planned so she was more
disappointing
so maybe it'll still work next year
maybe maybe wasn't timely that she can
reuse that bit actually I was funny
because she wasn't sad about losing the
award she was sad that she didn't get to
do her bit that she had planned so that
was amazing she's amazing I've accepted
speeches I love that